brach thank you so much for coming on et
Canada pride thank you for having me I'm
really excited to have you here because
I think you have such a great story that
a lot of people and youth from the LGBTQ
community should know about tell me
about where your love of sports came
from oh goodness
my family yeah I from a young age I was
just immersed in it my dad played hockey
baseball and a bunch of different sports
and so did all my uncles and relatives
on both sides really my mom's side as
well and I just kind of was always
exposed to it so it sort of was a
natural path for me where are some ear
highlights from your hockey career would
you say playing in the OHL was a big
highlight having that opportunity to
play at the top level in the province at
a young age
moving on to professionally to play
professionally was really you know a
prideful moment for me especially
everything I was going through
personally at that time and going back
to school I went back to school and
played a youth sport hockey and and
working at my degree well I got to play
the sport I love yeah when did you first
realize that maybe you were a member of
the LGBTQ community it's funny I
remember watching a movie with my
parents when I was six years old and
there was a gay character and I said to
them when I said what if I'm gay and
they said if you're gay you're gay
you're Brock we love you
Wow yeah and I remember going back to my
room with crying yeah but it's stuck
with me yeah that moment stuck with me
for a very long time and and as I hit
puberty and and start to have you know
those urges I start to recognize oh I'm
not enjoying what the other guys in the
room are talking about yeah so it was
probably around that age really where it
really hit me in 1213 I mean the hockey
and sports environment for a member of
the LGBTQ community is not an easy one
to be in some of the language that is
used in the locker rooms can you talk to
me about that and how that made you feel
realizing that maybe you were dead
i from a young age start to hear sexist
and homophobic language and ultimately
there's racist language as well in
sporting and locker rooms in general
yeah
but the sexist language and homophobic
language really stuck with me it because
the sport is so hyper masculine men tend
to put each other down within the sport
by either feminizing or using homo'
negative language and that homo negative
language it's like saying that this is a
man and if you're a woman or you're gay
you're less than a man yeah
and I sat there and I thought like oh
jeez I can't be this I can't be this
because like that I can't play hockey
yeah and and from a very young age I
tried to suppress who I was due to that
tell me about the moment when you
realize that you were over hiding your
sexuality by the age of 18 I started
drinking daily I was suicidal I hate him
myself every day I want to die I
couldn't even look at myself in the
mirror that went on for years finally at
23 I was living in Europe I was living
just outside of Amsterdam and would have
been a really cool place to be gay yeah
but I was hiding it and I finally
stopped myself down one day and I'd had
my career derailed I went from being on
a neutral draft list probably being a
pict all of a sudden playing minor
leagues of Europe and sat myself down
and I said you need to figure this out
because I knew two things were going to
happen one my career was coming to an
end to us are you to end up dead you
can't drink every day for five years be
suicidal be depressed and all this and
not have you know a bad outcome so I
came back to Toronto after my season and
I went on a date with men and I said yep
this is me I ended up dating him for
over three years
Wow it was until a years later at 32 I
came out publicly yeah and at that point
my parents knew I told them a year or
two in advance and and they were so
supportive my entire family was my
brother was a professional hockey player
i sat him down I said Cory I'm gay and
he said yeah
so I know it's like really that's it
yeah but my family was incredibly
supportive of me and they just wanted me
to have and I'm very privileged in that
regard that I have such a supportive
loving family that just wanted me to be
happy
yeah because not everybody has though
there's a lot of youths out there who
struggle with coming out because they're
afraid to lose their family their
friends their career completely I see it
all the time I mean I travel around now
speaking and the day I came out I had
over 10,000 messages now and a lot of
them were from people struggling and
that's what made me realize wow I have a
platform yeah when you go to events and
do inclusivity training what are you
teaching people when you go and do that
my message predominantly through my talk
is is geared towards the hetero audience
on how to be either a better ally or
just a Peter yeah
and and for me I see the biggest shift
that still needs to happen today
especially in Canada where we are more
inclusive is language I think especially
with younger generations they're far
more inclusive in thought yeah but their
language hasn't evolved as quickly as
their thoughts have and I think that's
still stems from what I said earlier
about hockey culture filtering into our
mainstream culture so I think that plays
into that and for LGBTQ people I want
them to recognize that only they can
accept themselves and if they learn to
accept themselves and love themselves
they will be able to get past any hatred
or homophobia they experience people
always say as an LGBTQ member we get to
choose our family so I think it's
important for people to remember that
yes if your coming-out may lose your
family if that's a reason you will find
a new family I'm a big believer as game
men we need a community yeah we need a
community of other gay men who
of similar experience to ourselves
because even if you look at our history
we aren't taught lgbtq+ history by our
parents or anyone in our lives because
they have an experience it's very
different than any other minority group
in that sense so we don't know ourselves
we don't know the struggle we don't know
about the AIDS epidemic we don't know
about
Stonewall I mean most people hopefully
know about Stonewall but we don't know
about the bathroom or bath house raids
in Toronto or Matthew Shepard or
different stories like that that are so
important to our community and the
people who fought for our rights to be
able to love ourselves and love who we
love and and I think it's so important
to find that community and and not just
you know dating apps and everything are
great but it's it's tough if you're
hooking up with everyone to then have
that friend group and you need that
solid foundation and group that becomes
your family the homophobic slur that was
allegedly said it recently at an NHL
game I have to talk to you about that
of course blame it first was put on
Morgan and they have said that Morgan
did not say it so where are we now do
you think first of all did the NHL
handle that situation properly
I think the Leafs handled it well I'm
gonna separate the Leafs in the league
sure I think Toronto Kyle dubis is a
very inclusive person I've known Kyle
since he was 15 a great person he was
one of the first people to reach out to
me when he came when I came up Brendan
Shanahan
I've sat down with him on a number of
occasions she's the president of team
and and talked about these things and
he's a phenomenal individual as well
incredibly inclusive incredibly
insightful and progressive they both are
from what I gather about Morgan I've
never met Morgan Rielly however I've
heard the same things about him so I
tend to give him the benefit of the
doubt yeah that said somebody said
something
and I really don't know if the NHL's
still investigating it we've said Morgan
didn't say it but who did but who did
and you and I think it's important that
we get to the bottom of that so do i and
and I I don't know if they will ever I
think it's kind of been swept under the
rug but we've seen this from the league
in the past with different incidents
there's an incident with Ryan Getzlaf
where he made homophobic comments and
the league deemed them not homophobic
yeah and there's constantly been
instances like this that they have to be
better at because they have such a
social impact on our culture that bite
allowing somebody to say those words
it's it's allowing kids to say those
words it's giving validation to
homophobic people and I think it's
really important that people recognize
that you can't say that I tried to kill
myself on a number of occasions just
from that language yeah and they need to
recognize that that has such a massive
impact kids are quitting hockey kids are
quitting sport they want nothing to do
with it at a young age because they're
queer and they don't feel comfortable
around it yeah and that's horrible I
mean if a player is caught saying you
know homophobic or racist language in
your opinion I mean people in the past
have been fined you know $5,000 $10,000
sit out a game or two is that enough in
your opinion I know you've mentioned you
don't like punishment but that kind of
behavior for somebody who is such a
leader what should happen well here's my
theory on it if that would have been a
racist comment I think more would be
done to figure out who said 100% agree
with you I think because it was a
homophobic comment it swept under the
rug and it's very ironic that it's from
a league that has a month called
hockey's for everyone where they sell
LGBT merch right and different things
they have pride nights and and for me
personally I think if you're going to do
that you better you know back it up with
action whether it's the Maple Leafs or
the Yankees or the New England Patriots
when you have a major franchise that
where it and that's the location where
it happened
now hopefully it'll
move the conversation for not just a
conversation but because I heard that
being said quite often in the last week
but now hopefully it'll move
you know steps towards putting
sustainable programs in place yeah but
what kind of weight does it carry to
have that title of being like the first
professional openly gay hockey player
because it's incredible well thank you I
never anticipated being this I really
didn't I knew I would do advocacy or
activism work something in this world
but I look back at 2011 and I was
friends with Brendan Burke and Brendan's
Astana Brian Burke who's you know in the
media now and used to be that used to
run the Toronto Maple Leafs and Brendan
wood came out as gay and he wants to
follow in his father's footsteps and he
was a friend of mine and I reached out
to him after he came out and it was just
one of the first people I ever told when
he passed on and even before he passed
on he had put this in my mind to do this
type of thing I think there needs to be
a two-tiered model where we educate fans
this fan cultures incredibly toxic yep
players at professional levels
management coaches at professional
levels and then take them down to minor
sports and do a grassroots initiative
where as you're educating these people
educating these kids and then it kind of
slowly gradually improves so if you're
educating 10 year olds on what you can
and can't say and the importance of in
why it's going to hurt somebody maybe
they'll stop it's maybe that gay kid in
the room will feel more comfortable
you
you